Health information exchange is essential
for care coordination, managing
populations of patients, public health
and aggregating data for research.
However, there are still many challenges
that have proven hard to overcome,
despite years of effort.
Perhaps most importantly, it's difficult
to establish a sustainable business
model beyond the confines
of a healthcare enterprise,
which has its own proprietary business
reasons for supporting an HIE.
There's also the inevitable trade-off
between functionality and cost.
Centralized models like IHIE deal
with data interoperability issues and
can provide extensive services,
but at a high cost.
New virtually free models, like Direct,
are not yet providing services
nearly as rich as IHIE, but we've
discussed how that might be changing.